This is a story of success amongst the hundreds of thousands of central
Europeans who left Europe to go to America and search of a better life.
Some found out that America's promises were OUS. Many though,
managed to establish a decent living and some even achieved spectacular success.
This demonstrated that this was perhaps the right country to welcome a young
immigrants with the right work ethic,
a unique talent and some sharp business acumen.
This is the story of a Hungarian boy who went to America,
ands became one of the most successful entertainers of all time known as the
master of escape. He was of course, Harry Houdini, uh, Acrobat, contortionist,
magician, escape, artist, entrepreneur, film, TACU debunker, a cultist,
and maybe even a secret agents above all else.
Harry Houdini was a master marketer,
ands manager of his own public image using a variety of media to
promote his shows and his famous stunts that would defy death and leave it
empty handed every time. So today Harry Houdini,
the closest America got to having a real life superhero.
Our hero was born on the 24th of March, 1874 in Budapest,
aro Hungarian empire with a name of Eric vice.
He was one of seven children born to Samuel.
And so Cecilia who had married in 1863,
Samuel had started in life as a soap maker and he had certainly had intellectual
ambitions.
He graduated as a doctor in law and did also studied to become a rabbi and a
Bible scholar eventually becoming a civil servant in Budapest.
His career must have hit a hard stock.
There was the vice family was forced to immigra to the us in 1887 in search of
fortune and a better life. This hard stop,
according to some sources was an event worthy of a novel by Aandra Dumar father
of the three Musketeers.
It seems that Samuel had challenged and killed in a deal Austria-Hungarian
nobleman known only Eric to prevent prosecution.
He had organized to escape to America with the help of a good friend called Carl
Herman, who you may find it amusing to know was at the time,
one of the most famous stage magicians in Europe,
it is foreshadowing to say the least that the early life of he who had become
Harry Houdini were to be influenced by an escape aided by a stage
magician.
This version of events may be corroborated by the fact that according to other
sources, Samuel fast,
left alone for the states followed by the rest of his family at a later stage,
whatever the reasons for this escape or immigration,
the vice family had their surname changed to Weiss in Ellis island.
They ever creative immigration officers also re christened young Eric as Eric
Yay. Eric and his family initially lived between Appleton and Milwaukee and
Wisconsin.
Eric demonstrated a very early talent for athleticism becoming very early on a
proficient runner swimmer and amateur boxer.
The history channel mini series that in 2004 portrayed a relationship with his
father is fractures and dysfunctional. In reality,
Eric was very close to Samuel who encouraged Eric SU interest in acrobatics and
stage magic by taking him to circus and carnival shows in 1883.
In fact, Eric started his career as a performer becoming a,
he was able to perform feet such as bending over backwards in a bridge position
to pick up a pin from the floor with his teeth.
He also learns very early on how to dislocate his shoulders or rather joints
from their sockets in order to increase his flexibility.
These early displays of stagecraft were absolutely not opposed by Samuel and
Ceia.
The Weiss found difficult to make a living though Samuel's career as a rabbi had
not fully picked up since he moved to America.
And any job that ELIC and his siblings could pick up was very welcome for the
family finances. This was demonstrated by very sad event on Christmas Eve, 1885,
the oldest of the white siblings, Herman.
He died of tuberculosis at the age of just 22.
It was Eric who paid for the funeral expenses.
Thanks to his earnings as a performer.
When Eric turned 13, he and Samuel moved to New York.
It was here that the preteen added acrobatics to his talents,
performing as AE artist with stage names,
such as prince Eric or the prince of the air during the same period, young,
Eric would pick up another talent that would become key to his later career.
He became the apprentice of a locksmith, the line of work,
which made him become fascinated with the locks of any kind and how to pick them
open.
It is reported that he developed such skills that he stunned his employer on at
least two occasions.
The time that he managed to open a pair of handcuffs using only a piece of piano
wire. And when he unlocked all of the doors in the shops on his street,
just for the hell of it, with a combination of these talents at problematics,
contortion and lock picking, Alec could have easily gone on to become a Burg.
And who knows,
maybe we'd be here talking about how he pulled off the most successful heist in
history, but luckily he soon found another career to channel his talents.
Surely more honest, but by no means any less risky
At the age of 17 I and his brother Theo,
they worked on developing a magical act,
which they would perform at so-called penny circuses, musicals side shows,
and at new York's Coney island amusement park, as they grew in popularity,
I thought it was wise to choose a stage name.
Eric Theo used to call themselves Hart dash.
So the first names were sorted as for the last name.
Harry went for Houdini after one of his idols, French illusionist, Robert Hoar,
the Houdini brothers would perform up to 20 shows every single day.
Their partnership continued in until 1894 when they met another in entertainer
teenage singer and dancer, well hung,
AOUS better known as BES at that time.
BES was part of an act called the floral sisters and it initially started dating
dash, but after she and Harry met, they were smiting with each other.
It was a real Kuda food.
Harry and BES, courted got engaged and married in the span of one week.
In addition to being life partners,
they also became partners on the stage as best replaced dash as Harry sidekick.
So at this point of the story, we probably should feel sorry for dash Whodini,
AKA Theo vice the poor guy had been basically pushed to the side twice by his
brother romantically and professionally. It's no one,
then that the two would develop a bit of rivalry, right? Well wrong again,
but I'm not going to leap ahead. Like A's artist,
I'm going to stick to BES and Harry's love story for now.
BES and Harry remained deeply in love for the rest of their lives.
And maybe even after Harry gave her credit for many of his achievements and
developed the habit of writing her a love letter every single day,
sometimes when they were on top, Harry would write a letter,
even when sitting in the same hotel room as up it is widely reported that the
couple were largely faithful to each other.
Despite the temptations that a famous magician may incur when meeting his fans.
Well, actually Harry did not a hundred percent stick to his marital vows.
He had at least one confirmed and documented affair with a lady called SHA in
London.
The wife of a famous novelist Jack London best on the other hand was much more
serious only on one occasion to make Harry jealous.
She sat on the lap of a young Colonel at a party. The RS worked Houdini.
The man who had defi death,
thousands of times on and off stage was terrified at the,
to his wife sitting on some other guy's lap for months afterwards,
the mention of the kernel would get him into a funk in 1895,
the Houdini joined the Welsh brothers circus for six months.
Harry performed his magic tricks while best sang and danced together.
They devised an illusion called metamorphosis in which they switched places in a
locked trunk, as fast as the bat of an eyelet over the same period,
Harry and best wild audiences by performing a spiritualist on stage.
In other words, acting as mediums to some of the spirits of the debt.
It was all an act of course, but performed very convincingly.
Harry apparently got best into a trance and in the spirits would use her as a
mouthpiece to communicate with the living.
Harry's favorite approach was to ask the spirits about recent unsolved murders
is in the town where they were performing.
It is out on one occasion that one of the spirits revealed the identity of a
murder at the man who was sitting among the audience,
jumped from his suit and fled the scene.
Was the story true or display the many publicity stunts that Harry would pull
over the years PR it was indeed one of the many skills that Harry mastered
alongside his most visible and memorable endeavor. And that's of course,
the art of escape.
When arriving in a new town, Houdini issued a challenge.
The local police department,
he would be able to escape from any handcuffs provided by the local offices.
If he failed, he would offer a reward of $100. As you may have guessed.
He never had pay this type of stunt.
It would bring an increasing attention from the press and free promotion for his
show to the points that he became a headliner on the VOR Deville circuit in
1899, Harry got his first big break,
a VOR Deville in Presario called Martin Beck,
encouraged Tini to focus his shows on escapes,
any type of escape from handcuffs, chains, locks, trunks, and shackles.
That course booked him on a tour of Europe,
which would be a turning point in the magician's career. The following year, Mr.
And Mrs. Houdini,
they sailed to England for their first engagement in a London theater as ever.
He ensured his success with the clever PR stunt Houdini wowed audiences.
And Bobby is alike when he successfully broke free from handcuffs placed on him
by arguably the best police department in the world, Scotland yard,
according to boths William collusion, Larry Lowman,
this stunt impress the head of Scotland yard, William Melville,
who initiated Houdini to his parallel secret career,
that of a spy in his majesty service.
So was Houdini actually a spy.
The idea is so enticing that indeed a mini series about Houdini spying on the
French, the Russians and the Germans would be pretty excellent.
The claim is also pretty credible. There's a famous performer.
Barry would have been able to,
to all of Europe disturbed and have access to high ranking officials.
If he ever got caught, well, good luck restraining him,
but some disappointing use. He wasn't.
The theory has been debunked by several authors. First of all,
the British secret intelligence service was not established until 1909.
Also by 1900 Houdini was not yet famous enough to presume that he would be able
to perform for the Kaiser or anyone powerful that,
but the best counter argument comes from fellow magician and professional
debunker. The great James Randy,
if Houdini had been a spy that would've gotten out,
he never would've been able to sit on it. So let's get on with our tour.
In November of 1900,
Harry invited his brother dashed to join him for the rest of his European tour.
Was this, uh, reconciliation for two brothers? Well, no,
but only because there was never a rift between the two.
They always remained friends and collaborators. Harry had a plan.
He had helped dash in launching his career as a magician and escape artist with
the stage name of hard Dean,
which sounded close enough to Houdini as Harry and be toward European theaters.
Hard Dean would follow suit and book performances in venues that Harry play.
This was a scheme to shut out of the market.
The many cheap imitators of Harry's escape art at the same time,
raking an additional revenue that would stay in the family.
The suppose rivalry was also part of the R the two brothers simply fed this fake
piece of news to the press.
Knowing very well that this created even more free advertising for their shows,
on least one occasion, dashed the harden, whatever you want to call him,
even pioneered an act that would become one of Harry's best known routines,
the straight jacket escape. Meanwhile,
the publicity from the Scotland art escape had caused Houdini's fame to spread
across the channel, sold out engagements,
followed in Germany and then across other European countries.
In addition to leaving police forces baffled, Harry came up with another,
a to attract attention and that's jumping into rivers,
fully chains and handcuffed with statistically Houdini would remain underwater
long after traffic removed his shackles,
allowing the suspense to build among the audience with his blast remaining
breath. He would then emerge from under the water waving triumphantly.
This was performance art,
gorilla marketing and viral promotion all rolled into one
In 1905 Harry and best returned to the United States.
He had become an international celebrity by now in the public where expecting
increasingly daring exploits from him. And when he satisfied them,
I already mentioned the straight jacket act.
Perry was able to set himself free from such a contraption,
thanks to his ability to self dislocate his shoulders from their sockets in pure
Martin rigs style. But that was too easy.
So Houdini would perform the act while hanging upside down from a skyscraper
in these cities that he was touring in and not just any skyscraper as we've
already established. Houdini was a marketing and PR pioneer.
So he picked buildings that housed major newspapers.
This ensure the photographers got the best shots of him and the great Houdini
would make to headlines. Unsurprisingly,
his shows sold out his Trump from return to America was the setting for the
creation of increasingly outrageous identifying acts.
You've probably heard about or seen images of the most famous ones. For example,
the milk can escape.
Houdini was shackled and lowered into an industrial size milk cannon.
Then it was filled with water and hidden behind a curtain though.
He was usually able to escape in three minutes.
Harry frequently stayed the curtain for up to half an hour,
making his reappearance even more dramatic than what can was the setting for one
of his rare failures in one performance,
the can was filled with beer rather than water.
This sounds like great fun to you and me.
But Houdini was a tea Toler in the effects of the alcohol,
knocked him out for Wie, had to be pulled to safety by stage hands.
Another famous example was the act called upside down,
but which the press rebranded as Chinese water torture chamber Houdini would
have his feet shackled his hands handcuffed,
and then he would be placed upside down inside a transparent tank,
filled with water to increase the suspense,
sometimes invited the audience to hold their breath for as long as it took him
to emerge from the chamber, one less known,
but more bizarre stunt was a one-off of their,
and that took place in September of 1911 in Boston,
some businessmen challenged Houdini to attempt to escape from inside the car of
a 1,500 pound sea monster that had washed up in Boston's Harbor.
It was not clear what the monster was,
maybe whale or a giant leatherback turtle. In any case,
Houdini accepted the challenge in front of thousands of spectators.
Harry was handcuffed,
shackle old and wedged inside the stinking car Tini emerged after 15 minutes.
Normally he would've done away with the iron much more quickly,
but he was nearly poisoned by the chemicals that had been used to embalm them on
step by now,
he was one of the most famous celebrities in America and certainly was the most
famous stage magician slash master lock picker.
But there is more to life than just stage magic and picking locks and Harry's
vivid C seated not allow him to stagnate on just one talent in the
1910s and early 1920s.
He sought to diversify his activities driven by patriotism, love of adventure,
love of justice, or simply to make a few extra bucks,
which well they're all perfectly fine motivations during a second tour of Europe
in 1909,
Harriet developed a love for aviation and had bought a voice in by plane mate in
France.
It's also interesting to note that he was one of the first private pilots in
March of 1910.
Houdini was touring Australia and took three short flights with his VA on near
Melbourne.
This was certified at the time as the first powered flight to take place down
under making Harry Houdini a pioneer of aviation plus I'm sure I got him a few
extra headlines and ticket sales along the way.
A few years later and back in the states,
Harry volunteered to serve the government in a time of need in April, 1917,
the us entered the war against the central empires.
And although Houdini was theoretically Austria-Hungarian,
he was staunchly loyal to his country of adoption in 1917 and 1980.
He canceled his tours to entertain soldiers instead,
and to raise money for the war effort.
He even organized some lessons for the troops where he taught them how to free
themselves. If they were made captive by the Germans,
not all his extra magician activities were successful though between 19,
19 and 1923 Houdini tried his hand movie stardom.
He was the lead in the master mystery before deciding to create his own
production company with the help of dash,
the Houdini pitch corporation released the man from beyonds and Hal of the
secret service. These two films tanked the box office. It seemed like Harry,
after all could fail too. Anyways, by the beginning of the 1920s,
Houdini had other preoccupations on his mind.
This is when he started a parallel career as a debunker of a cultist,
spiritualists and mediums in general,
he would expose as fake anybody who claimed to communicate with the dead,
which is ironic given his early performances,
what Houdini could not tolerate was the exploitation of well-meaning individuals
who were wanting to commute communicate with their deceased, loved ones.
He campaigned with further often visiting sounds as in disguised to expose
their ringleader as frauds when he could not go in person.
He sent one of his team of detectives.
He would go to sounds as on his behalf and to bring back information
information,
which allowed him to set up shows entirely dedicated to exposing the tricks used
by a mediums.
Houdini offered a $10,000 reward to any psychic who could present physical
phenomenon that could not be explained rationally.
The psychics were to be investigated by a committee from the scientific American
publication. One of the mediums under the lens was well known.
Spiritualist mean a CRS known as Marjorie Marjorie attempted to seduce several
members of the committee to S secure the prize.
And she even made a pass at Harry Houdini was not easily charmed and de said of
her. Her apple source means nothing to me.
Houdini's crusade culminated in 1926.
When he testified before the us Congress in support of a bill to outlaw the
practice of pretending to tell fortunes for reward or compensation,
the bill was made into law. Albeit a only in the district of Columbia,
I should clarify.
Now the Tini debunking efforts were not entirely based on pure skepticism.
In fact, Harry did believe in a spiritual world.
He just simply did not trust Charlotte's who claims they could access it.
His belief in it thereafter was put to the test by an experience which involved
one of his dearest friends, sir, Arthur koan, Doyle, ER Arthur's main creation.
Sherlock Holmes was a Palladin for rational thinking.
And yet the author family believed that the dead could talk to the living lady.
Doyle shared this belief and had a reputation for being an accomplished medium
in 1922 S Arthur and lady koan,
Doyle organized for Houdini and automatic writing seance that supposedly
contacted his beloved mother. So Cecilia who had died nine years earlier.
So Cecilia's spirit convincingly took control of lady doll's body,
but Houdini was not easily fooled white.
Did the wife of a rabbi do the sign of the cross?
Why a Hungarian immigrant who never learned English suddenly was writing in that
language, this seance.
It was the beginning of the end of Houdini's relationship with S Arthur Ko and
Doyle, and may have fueled his animosity towards mediums.
While touring in Montreal,
Canada Houdini was visited by two students of McGill university in his dressing
room. It was the 22nd of October, 1926. One of them, Jay Gordon,
white had asked Harry if he could really absorb any punch to the stomach,
Harry replied that yes he could.
And then the student suddenly punched him four times probably having
misunderstood the replies and invitation to do so.
Houdini had a terrible stomach pain for two days before.
Finally seeing a doctor, Harry is found to have a high fever and cue to pen.
He was advised to go to the hospital for surgery,
but he preferred to go on stage and complete the show by the middle of the third
act,
Houdini lowered the curtain and collapsed Bess and dash had taken to a hospital
where his appendix was removed, but it was too late.
It had already rupture on October the 31st Halloween, 1926,
Harry Houdini died with Bess and da Ash at his bedside.
The official cause of death was acute peritonitis caused by the appendix being
ruptured by an ill timed punch.
You have heard the theory that Houdini was actually the victim of a spiritualist
conspiracy, but there's absolutely no evidence of that.
Houdini's funeral was held on November the fourth, 1926,
New York with more than 2000 mourns in attendance in the year that followed best
held annual senses. Every Halloween to contact Harry.
The last sounds took place exactly 10 years after Harry's death.
And it was broadcast over the radio. After over an hour of silence,
Mrs. Houdini decided to end the experiment as Harry's spirit would just remain
silent. As the sounds came to an end,
a violent thunderstorm broke out the participants sitting on a hotel rooftop
Harris were drenched by the violent rainfall while lightning set the sky,
a blaze,
they would late and learn that the storm did not occur anywhere else in the
area. Only above the sounds location,
I would not be surprised to learn if this was a stunt of Houdini,
a final way to say goodbye. So I really have you found that video in.
Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below and Don get to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos just like this four times per week.
So subscribe hit that notification bell and as always, thank you for watching.